(lively piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal.
Naked
Large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
we hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights
on who we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(uptempo music)
(upbeat music)
So, I'm Rusty Gage.
I'm the, as she said,
I'm one of the co-directors with Margaret
and Ajit and Pascal.
And one of the co-sponsors of today's
presentation to you all.
I'm gonna give you a little bit of a
explanation for why we're
having this meeting today,
how we came about
doing this meeting,
and I'm also gonna give
you the first of our
presentations today on my approach
and take to this.
So, some of you are
long time participants in the symposia
and will be somewhat intimidated
probably by the title of
this current presentation,
Cellular and Molecular Mechanisms
that are underlying or the evolving
the differences between
humans and non-human primates.
So, probing the molecular
cellular differences.
Remember what Ajit told us,
he said that our goal
is to really understand
where we came from.
how did we get here
and what is the mechanism
or what is the way in which this happened,
And in truth most of what we've
been talking about for many years is
the ways in which we actually examine this
is by looking at DNA from
post-mortem tissue from
our closest relatives,
even neanderthals now,
and sequencing that DNA
and comparing with humans
and looking for the
difference that exists.
We have post-mortem tissue itself
where we can look at brain structures
and see how they may have
changed with evolution,
anatomical kinds of information.
And of course, at the core of it we have
archeological evidence for bones
where we can get brain casts
and look at how the
brain size has changed,
and even if you get a good cast
you can see how certain areas of the brain
have grown more in different species
or different evolving creatures over time,
these endocasts.
And finally we have archeological evidence
that gives insights into
perhaps even the thought
processes that were going on
while our species were evolving.
In the case of DNA we have genes.
In the case of the post-mortem
tissue we have tissues
and slices and histological evidence.
With bones we have inferences
about size and structure.
And of course archeological
evidence we have
cultural implications.
And so a missing piece
for this for a lot of us
has been really what we
consider to be mechanisms
at the level of cellular
and molecular events.
And there's a growing
interest in this piece here
and we call it the missing link.
It's joke just to get the.
(audience laughs)
Missing link in the sequence of events
and there are some recent technologies
that have been developed
that have allowed us
to get insights into tissues.
One is using what you'll hear a bit about
which is called induced pluripotent cells.
This is the ability to take somatic cells
from any species
and convert them into a embryonic cell
that can be differentiated into
all cells of the body including neurons.
So, for living organisms that we normally
can't penetrate and see
how their brain functions,
we can now look at behavioral function,
look at the genes while they're active,
while they're alive.
In addition you'll hear a lot about
model organisms where once
genes have been identified
that might have implications
for certain growth patterns,
that are unique to humans,
they can be tested
experimentally in living animals,
different species that reveal to us
how that unique change in the gene
may have fostered a meaningful change
that is relevant to how it is
that we became who we are.
That's the motivation
and on a personal note I would say that
my hope is, my hopes are
always mixed with worries,
the worry is not that we develop
a whole new area of research
that just looks in towards ourselves
explaining more and more about
the cellular molecular mechanisms,
but rather that these
new tools become vehicles
for expanding outward
into the other panoply
of ways in which we can study evolution.
There's an emerging idea now,
sort of re-emergence
of a concept in science
called convergent science.
It was a term that was modified
from the concept of consilience
but it is the idea that
different levels of science that normally
talk specifically to themselves
begin to understand how they can transmit
information from one level to a next,
and that's how we believe or hope
that new concepts and
deeper thoughts will emerge.
So, our challenge as most of us
as cellular molecular biologists
that are speakers in this symposium
is to think about how we
can use this information,
to stretch this and expand
to these other areas
that are so important for understanding
the underlying principles.
All right with that I will
present the first presentation.
And hopefully this will act a little bit
as an introduction to the
concepts that we're trying to present.
I'm gonna very specifically
talk about modeling
human evolution remarkably in a dish
and this involves this
technology I talked to you about
called induced pluripotent cells
which I'll go into in some depth.
Now studying evolution in a dish
has advantages and disadvantages.
Comparison between humans,
what we're really comparing
are these particular cell types
and not the full organisms.
But the hope is that
or the belief is that much
of the critical changes
that have occurred occur in the brain.
And that this transition
point from early brain cells
to mature brain cells is that period of
maturation within a cell lineage
wherein much of the
magic happens that will
be seen as the known
or unknown differences
between humans and our closest relatives.
And as you'll hear
some common themes emerging
from these speakers
that these early, very early events,
there's real differences
that are occurring in human species
relative to our common relatives.
Now the advantage of this approach is that
we can obtain somatic
cells or skin biopsies,
and now this technology can be done with
pretty much any somatic cell.
But you can you can obtain
them from many species
and very non-intervention manner.
We've been developing
basically a cellular zoo now
for the last eight or 10
years where we collect
biopsies from species,
a variety of different species
and I'll be talking to you about
these species from human, bonobo, chimp,
gorilla and rhesus.
And in particular you should remember that
the chimps and bonobos share
significant amount of their genome
and yet the brain size difference between
our brains and our closest relatives
is really quite striking,
we'll have more about that.
And other differences are that
in this last period of seven
million years when we evolved,
many of the genes, many of the diseases
that have evolved appear
to be unique to humans.
So, along with the acquisition
of the unique features
that it is to be human we've
also acquired susceptibility
to a variety of diseases.
And so, one of the advantages
or one of the goals of understanding
the cellular molecular
underlying mechanisms
that are involved in
human species evolution
will tell us about the unique
features of these diseases.
So in this particular case we've acquired
pluripotent stem cells
from a variety of species.
We take the cultures,
we grow them in dishes
and we treat them exactly the same.
And we use a series of
chemical modifications
and structural modifications
to change these fibroblasts
into what amounts to
an embryonic stem cell.
And this is called induced pluripotency
and in the end we have a series
of clonal populations of cells
that can grow indefinitely.
And under the right conditions,
these cells can be induced
to differentiate into neurons
of a variety of different types.
And it's this ability
to be able to look at
each of the different stages.
So we can look at the early
stages of somatic cells
as they're growing in a dish as iPS cells
or as the intermediates that lead to
differentiation of different cell types.
Now obviously there are limitations
and we should be, we're aware of those.
We're examining intrinsic differences
that can be detected in
these individual cells.
There must be a genetic
or an epigenetic event
that is underlying any phenotype
or difference that we can detect.
Culture, when I say there
are cultural differences
in this case I mean tissue
culture not advanced culture.
Social experience is something
that's very difficult to,
we're not going to capture
that social acquired knowledge.
Dietary kinds of events are difficult to
completely capture.
And of course I'll tell you a
little bit about our attempts
to get in vivo context by transplantation.
And it's really question whether or not
the in vitro relevancy of the
phenotypes that we look at,
how well do they transfer.
That takes additional
kinds of experiments.
But what it really comes down to
is are there differences
that are detectable
at the cellular level
that are relevant to the
understanding of human origins?
So, there are some basic features
that we could look at right away
and we know that for example,
humans have 46 and chimp
have 48 chromosomes.
That they express certain
genes that identify
the most primitive state.
So we can look for those to make sure that
when we do the conversion
they are retained within a certain fate.
And we can test whether or not these
embryonic stem cells that we get
behave equivalently or not equivalent.
So it's really important
right the very beginning
to determine whether or not
we're seeing differences or not
so we can monitor them with a variety
of known differences.
So here are some simple ways
in which we can do this morphologically
and genetically determine by karyotyping
the chromosomes that are inherent,
and whether or not there's any
gross differences between them.
Whether or not the cells
grow at the same rate,
whether or not they
express the same genes.
And in our first attempts at this now,
years ago we first started
by looking at these immature cells,
these iPS, what they called
induced pluripotent cells
to see if we could determine
any differences between them.
And we did this by extracting DNA
and we looked for the
expression of all the genes
that were expressed in these cells
between all the species
to see whether or not we could find
any fundamental differences
that were apparent at that early stage.
And I won't go through this in any depth
but back several years ago now
we reported that there were features
particularly interesting
to, interest to our lab
that there are genetic
elements in the brain
that had this capacity for hopping around
or jumping from one location to another.
And these genes were very
differently regulated
in chimps and bonobos relative to humans
to the extent that humans
had developed a mechanism
by expressing two particular genes
that suppressed the activity
of these line elements.
So, the amount of new elements
or new genetic material
that was added into the germ line
through this particular vehicle
was suppressed in humans
relative to our closest relative species
and by virtue of the over
expression of these genes.
We went on to hypothesize about this
and have continued working on
these early primitive cells
exploring this role that
these mobile elements play
in carving and crafting novel phenotypes
within not just in the human species
but in other organism as well.
One interesting point that I like to make
is that these line elements,
these increase in insertions
of these pieces of DNA
throughout the genome
add to the genetic
diversity of the offspring.
And we as humans have
suppressed this ability
to add this added element of diversity
which may mean a decrease in
behavioral diversity as well
limiting our genetic diversity.
Now this less genetic diversity
leads to a dependence now
more on cultural change for adaptation
to changes in the environment.
And we are exploring this as a hypothesis
for how humans are quite
similar to each other.
So what I'm going to
talk to you about today
is in the next few minutes is about
newer work looking at the next phase
of differentiation which are
these neural progenitor cells
and then subsequently neurons.
So we've developed a protocol where we can
generate cells into these very homogeneous
neural progenitor cells.
They express very unique and features
that we can compare across species.
And there are methodologies
now that allow us to
use unbiased methods to measure
all the genetic expression
that's unique to these cells
and compare them with one another.
When we do this across all the
species that we've looked at
from chimps, bonobos, gorillas
and rhesus versus humans,
we see 2,000 genes that are
differentially expressed
at a very, very high level.
And among them when we
look at clusters of genes
that have categories in
common called gene ontology,
we find that about a quarter of those
are genes that are involved
in how cells migrate
within a tissue situation.
So migration, the movement of neurons.
This seems to be a
feature that stands out.
So we set up an assay system to measure
whether or not we could
detect that genetic difference
in a functional difference.
This is an assay where the cells
are plated on a culture dish
and then we make a cut here
and then we ask how
quickly they can migrate
into their situation.
And we can monitor the cells
as they grow into this
and we can color them and
do this in a much more
high resolution where
we can track each cell
and look at the direction that it goes.
When we do this across multiple species
we find that humans are much slower
in their migratory pathway.
So by 24 hours this pathway is fully
aggregated together within migration.
Just as another example we can
look at this in another way,
looking at migration again
as a feature of these cells.
We can label the chimp cells in green,
sorry, in red and the human cells in green
and then mix them together
and put them at the bottom of
a dish that has micro grooves
where we can monitor and has a gradient
where we can monitor rate
at which the cells grow.
And this allows us to actually race
our two cells against each other
and see who can get there faster.
We can track again so it's
another method of this I think.
So, here we have and it really
depends on when the cells
get into the groove
and then you can start monitoring
how quickly they move.
So here's the green cells of the human
moving along the groove,
these are the grooves
that they're in here.
We're watching this cell move along.
Finally we get a a chimp cell in there
and the chimp cell sort
of takes off and moves.
Again evidence, another way
in which we can begin to
monitor these differences.
And when we do thousands of these movies
we see that both chimp and bonobo
are really quite similar in their rate
and direction of trajectory
as compared to the human which
appears to be much slower.
In a final assay here we did
a floating assay of cells
that migrate out from the central core
and we can measure the core of the cells
and the distance that they migrate.
And without much effort you
can see that the human cells
while plated to the
same density migrate out
over a period of time
at a much slower rate
relative to the other cells.
Now as a final assay
for this migration assay
we took advantage of the
fact we had colored cells
and we transplanted them into a mouse
that had a deleted immune system.
So it didn't recognize
the species difference
between humans and chimps versus itself.
So we could transplant
these cells directly
into the brain in various regions
and monitor the rate in
which they were migrating.
And I should say those people
who work in this field know
that human cells when implanted
tend to aggregate very closely.
So we weren't really
anticipating a difference
but it's really quite striking
when we examine these cells
months after the transplantation,
we see that there is or
but was noticed even as soon
as several weeks afterwards
that the human cells here aggregated
around the site of the injection,
whereas the chimp cells
migrated at a much greater rate.
And we could replicate this
or we could quantify
this very dramatically.
So we know now that human,
with all these assays put together
we can convince ourselves
that there really is this
intrinsic migration
deference which reflected
in the gene differences that
we can see between them.
Now that we can transplant these cells
we can watch their maturation into cells
and the sort of morphological changes
that happens to a neuron as it matures
is something that's
really well-documented.
And with a wonderful collaboration with
Katerina Semendeferi we were able to
and Bianca, our student, we were able to
monitor these changes in vivo
between chimp and human.
And the advantage is that
we're mixing the cells together
and injecting in the exact site
and can monitor them as they migrate away,
and then look at them over a period of,
in this case something like 19 or 19 weeks
and we're looking at a variety
of morphological features.
And strikingly, what we can do
is we can map each
individual dual cell in brain
and look how it morphologically develops.
So we can see them over
extended periods of time
and they're color coded
for us in the brain
so we can see what they, how they change.
Here you can see if we
look at dendritic length
they're pretty much the same
matching the same at these early stages.
And then humans dramatically take off
around six to eight weeks.
And another time we look at segments,
that's the number of branches they have
also separates at that period.
And then finally we have
the number of spines,
so these are the features
on each one of the dendrites
where connections are
coming into the cells.
So we see an accelerated differentiation
of the neural progenitor cells over time.
So as a final piece what we did
is there a functional consequence?
So we can measure actually
the electrical activity
whether or not they fire action potentials
in individual cells
and in these new devices
called a multi electrode array
we can plate the cells
and then bring them back
to the array and monitor their activity,
how they communicate with each
other over a period of time.
So they're resting on the
top of these electrodes
and we can measure their activity.
The system actually allows us
to monitor a variety of features.
We can measure not just the single spikes
but we can measure issues like bursting.
Whether or not they fire and bursts
or they, whether or not all,
many cells that are
connected with each other
fire at the same time.
So finally in this last
piece of information
I'll give you this final data.
The way you read this here at two weeks
each one of these is a
channel on which cells exist.
So here's the human cell.
We have a few of them, few
cells in there that are active
but clearly at two weeks the
chimp and the bonobo are both,
many many more cells are active
and not only that but you're
seeing some synchrony.
Meaning that cells are actually
connected to each other.
But by eight weeks, six weeks
here you have the humans now
bursting and synchronized
activity at a much higher rate
than the chimps evidencing once again
that there's this early
event where the chimps are
and the bonobos seem to be
maturing an accelerated rate
relative to the humans.
And we see this reflected not just
in the physiology here, the
chimps extending quickly
and then being bypassed there.
And again we have this window of time.
And the way we're beginning
to think about this
and I think it's consistent
with many, many others
is that in human evolution
there's a developmental delay,
retardation is not a really good word,
and/or what has been termed as neoteny
and in this case it doesn't fit exactly
because we're not looking at the endpoint,
but it is a developmental delay in humans
in their maturation that's been proposed
as a possible mechanism that
contributes to the rise of
many human species specific
including the increase in brain size
and the emergence of
human-specific cognitive traits.
So, we and others are interested in
this delay feature and
how this delay feature
may result in these morphological
and genetic features that we see.
And we'll be talking
more about the mechanisms
that may control this
sort of delayed event
which is so important for human evolution.
So conclusion, I hope
I've tried to convince you
that the iPS cell approach is,
we're able to generate
similar type cells in humans
and in non-human primates.
And there's a significant
amount of similarity
that underlies their maturation.
But we also discover
unique features that are,
now this is important, cell intrinsic
or the cell autonomous that
we can detect in vitro.
And this consistent feature reflects this
in the migration of the cells,
in the maturation of the dendrites
as well as its
electrophysiological activity.
So we think that these
approaches can be used
as a model to study the dynamic
developmental comparative differences
between humans and primates,
and non-human primates,
and the differences that this has
on an evolutionary perspective.
So as usual we have many people to thank.
A lot of that sort of
leader of this project
who's unfortunately was not able to attend
is Carol Marchetto.
A variety of people in
my own lab that have
more recently played a role in
various aspects of the analysis.
But Katerina Semendeferi and Branka
have been key players in
this morphological analysis
that they are experts at.
I have a variety of people
in our local CARTA group
that are important
and my close colleague Alysson Muotri
who's been with us on the beginnings,
right from the beginnings on this work.
And with that I want to
thank you for your attention.
(audience applauding)
Like many people here and
ever since I was a graduate
student at David Nelson's lab.
I've been interested in
the genetic basis of this
which is what makes the human brain
so unique compared to our most closest
related living relatives.
And I would argue that
and has already been alluded to
that geneticist have had
a problem for a long time
and this is partly
recognized by Allan Wilson
and Mary-Claire King is that the genomes
of humans and chimps are thought
to be virtually identical
but 1.1%, 1.2% genetic difference.
And I already alluded to that in fact
that the amino acid level of the proteins
they estimated half,
the number is closer to
about a third of the proteins
are identical between
the chimp and the human.
Yet when you compare
it to other organisms,
Drosophila you can compare to amphibians
even lizards that were
compared at that time
that Mary-Claire King was working on,
there are species that
have way more difference
in their amino acid compositions
and yet look virtually identical
in behavior and morphology.
And so this led to kind
of the speculation that
it must be regulatory changes
that make humans unique
or structural changes that
are actually important
in terms of shaping our DNA
in ways that couldn't be detected
at the level of amino acid differences.
So, I've been interested in
one very specific type of
mutation for a very long time,
duplicated sequences.
You might not think of
duplicated sequences as mutations
but they are.
They arise as everything
else as a mutation.
The initial duplication
is a mutational event.
They're important for genomes
for two very fundamental reasons.
Recognized for many years long before
molecular biology was even a word.
Susumu Ohno recognized this
and even before him others did,
that duplications are the primary force
by which new genes are
born within species.
Doesn't matter if you're a
chimp or a fly or a worm,
if you want to create a new gene
there's ways to do it that
and don't involve duplication
but the primary way is
to make an extra copy,
free it from a selective constraint,
new mutations occur, new function.
The second actually goes back earlier
from guys named Sturtevant
and Bridges and Muller
back into the 1930s is this idea that
when you duplicate sequence
and you create two sequences
that are virtually identical,
you've actually made the genome unstable.
So there's a process called
unequal crossing over
that can lead to unequal
crossing over events
that leads to gains and losses of sequence
right where the duplications live.
So, structurally dynamic
and the potential to
give birth to new genes.
I'm gonna to talk to you
a little bit today about
duplications, recent duplications,
things that have evolved over
the last 25 million years.
We call them segmental duplications.
They'll be duplications
within a chromosome.
They're interchromosomal duplications
and duplications within a
chromosome which we'll call
intrachromosomal duplications.
And here's a map that I've often showed.
This is some of the early work that we did
as part of the genome project
where we actually built the first
duplication map of the human genome.
So anything that you see here in blue
is an intrachromosomal duplication.
So that means it's duplicated
along the chromosome.
These are your chromosomes
schematically represented.
The purple represent
the regions that still
to this day haven't been sequenced
despite what people claim
that the genome is finished.
These are centromeres and acrocentric
and some telomeric portions
of the chromosomes.
The blue all represent the
intrachromosomal duplications
that are greater than 95% identical
and get greater than 10 kilobases in size.
So these are the biggest
events in our genome.
A couple things I want
you to get from this.
You can run the statistics
but you can see it by eye
that this distribution
is highly non-random.
Certain chromosomes,
chromosome seven, 15, 16
are particularly rich in this.
The second point I want
you to get from this
is that if you look at the pattern,
you see that a lot of these
lines actually go over
what appears to be long distances.
This is called an interspersed
pattern of duplications.
That means duplications are born
but when they are born they don't actually
stay close to one another but they in fact
distribute dispersed
from each one one another
by long distances.
In fact, if you do this
measurement and ask the question,
what fraction of our duplicated sequences
are actually separated from their ancestor
by at least a megabase,
are located on completely
different chromosomes?
And now there is something like 60%.
So this is your interchromosomal
pattern overlaid.
This is actually highly non-random as well
but it's non-random in terms
of regions of the genomes,
so near the ends of chromosomes
and near the centromeres are where those
predominantly live.
All right, so that's the pattern.
Why should you care?
Well the fact that you have interspersed
duplications in your genome
that are separated by
sometimes dozens if not
many dozens of genes,
means that the genes that live
between those duplicated sequences
are prone to be deleted
or duplicated themselves
because they are now inside a region
of instability in our genome.
And I'm not going to go into great detail
but there are now about
40 different genomic,
what is called these disorders
of which half of them
are mediated by recurrent
deletions primarily
but sometimes duplications
of the sequences
that are these recently evolved
duplicated parts of our genome.
So this is an example of
one that we discovered,
it's called the, with the others,
we discovered this back to back to back.
The Koolen-de Vries syndrome.
These kids have this region of the genome
only about a half a million base pairs
but it's deleted.
And so they are, parents have
two copies of chromosome 17
but the child has inherited
one that actually is missing
about 500 kilobases of sequence,
and that's because there are human
or great ape-specific duplications
located at the boundaries
of this sequence.
Here's another one that
we discovered in 2008.
This is a very specific form of autism.
These children are born with
the exact same kind of problem,
it's of a different portion of the genome
where there's duplications
that live right here
that caused this piece
of DNA to be deleted.
About three megabases of sequence
and about a dozen genes.
Every kid that's been born
that we've identified at least thus far
has a form of autism characteristics
by this frontal bossing of the forehead.
Very characteristic facial feature.
So it's a very rare form of
autism in the human species
caused by this duplication architecture.
This is an example of one
which doesn't actually have
any clear facial morphology.
This is a recurrent micro deletion
on again chromosome 15
once again meted by recently
evolved duplicated sequences.
These kids can either receive
kind of an inherited form
but more often they get a de novo
which means that it
happened in a germ line
of one of their parents.
Instead of just having one disease
these kids are at risk
for multiple diseases.
So it turns out that we identified
this associate with
intellectual disability
but relatively high functioning.
Later it was found to be
associate with autism.
associated 1% of epilepsy,
so idiopathic generalized epilepsy.
And papers from other labs
showed that it was an
important risk factor,
probably one of the biggest
ones for schizophrenia
in the adult population.
All right so, this is our
duplication architecture
and you could ask yourselves the question,
well, why do we have this organization?
It turns out when we go
to the genomes of mouse,
rats, dogs, cats, platypus
they don't have this type of organization.
They keep their duplications
organized in clusters
and little pockets
without being dispersed.
So this dispersal of
duplications has created
a bad design, pardon the pun.
It actually makes our
genome fragile essentially
because of the presence of
these duplicate sequences
that have evolved over the last
15, 20 million years of evolution.
Humans, chimps, gorillas,
we all share this
although the exact patterns are different
between chimps and gorillas.
And to a lesser extent
species like macaque
and marmoset have fewer
of these compared to
that of the great apes.
So, I'll say the answer, I
won't give you the answer
but you've actually
heard some of us today.
But just remember that
these are not basically gene
or regions of the genome.
There's about a thousand genes
and if you believe your
browsers that are out there
that aren't mapped in
these areas of the genome.
And Ohno argued that
this is a primary force
by which these new genes
evolve as duplication.
So before I tell you some stories,
I want to tell you a couple other features
of these duplications.
One is that their accumulation over time
has been non-random.
So work that was alluded to,
a work that I did with my
former postdoc, Tomas Marques.
We sequenced about 100 great ape genomes
to try to estimate which
duplications were fixed,
which duplications were polymorphic.
And there's generally accepted phylogeny
and the thickness of the lines
indicate roughly the proportion of
duplicated sequence that has
been fixed on any branch.
So the numbers are not that important
but for those of you were interested
what this means is for every
base that has been fixed
as a result of single base pair mutation
there have been 2.61 bases
that have been fixed in this branch
as a result of duplication.
But the really important
and I think relevant to
this audience is that
there is a huge excess, very statistical
in not in our branch but in
the common branch leading to
humans, chimps and gorillas.
This is where we see the biggest excess
of duplicated sequences
and almost all the duplications
that are causing disease in our species
associated with development
of delay in autism
are mapping to duplications
that evolved here,
and evolved right around the separation
of chimps, gorillas and humans.
Second point.
What I presented in
terms of the organization
was too simple.
So if you actually go and actually look at
the structures of these
duplications within a chromosome,
here's your chromosome 16.
And these little numbers here indicate
the structures that are
indicated on the right here.
Anything that you see in color
means that we've been able to determine
the evolutionary origin of the segment.
So whenever you see the same color
that means this came from the same origin,
in this case on chromosome 16.
And so, you get this
picture of duplications
that are made up of different
pieces of the genome
that have stitched together
to build these complex mosaics
or modular structures.
And then they, actually some are
very similar to one another
but some are actually very
different to one another.
But the really remarkable thing
and it's true for every chromosome
that has experienced this
burst of duplications
is that in those chromosomes you see
a specific sequence.
And this is indicated here by the red
we call it a Core Duplicon.
It is the place of the
genome where it seems to be
the focal point for the building up
to these more complex architectures.
This sequence is over-represented
way more than you'd expect by chance.
And it seems to actually be involved
somehow inherently in this duplication
and this interspersed
duplication architecture.
Moreover most of the recurrent
rearrangements that are
associated with disease
are meted by duplication
blocks that have these cores.
So we came up with the simple
hypothesis back in 2008.
Maybe the disadvantage of this
interspersed duplication
architecture is offset
by the emergence of new
genes with new functions
which override the actually
selective disadvantage of this
which is predisposing us to disease
or our children to disease.
And maybe contributing
to the unique features
that make us human,
i.e. the developing of the human brain.
So, is there any evidence?
So you've seen a version of this slide.
These were examples of the youngest
duplications that have evolved
and some of the genes are
listed here at the bottom.
This is the copy number that
we estimate in the genome
of multiple humans from
Asia, Europe and Africa
compared to chimp, orangutan and gorilla
shown here in gray and black.
These are human-specific
duplication events.
And one of the things
that we and Jim Sikela
noticed early on is that there is actually
a noticeable enrichment,
it's borderline significant
because there's not that many genes
of genes that have been implicated
in terms of brain development.
And what's really interesting
is if you actually look
at the chimpanzee-specific
or the gorilla-specific duplications,
you don't see these types of genes.
You see genes involved in immune response,
genes involved in drug detoxification
but you don't see these types of genes
actually being enriched.
So for example you've heard about
SRGAP2 and ARHGAP11B be at this meeting,
GTF2IRD is a transcription factor.
Thought to be important in
terms of visual-spatial defects
associate with the
Williams Syndrome disease.
GPIN, GPRIN is a G couple protein inducer
of neurite outgrowth.
CHRFAM7A is a related nicotinamide
acetylcholine receptor.
HYDIN is a gene that's
important in fluid flow
in terms of developing brain.
SMN1, survival motor neuron protein
and incredibly important in terms of
spinal muscular atrophy.
Two stories that you heard here.
In fact I think rise
above a just-so story.
The one you heard from
Franck all about SRGAP2C.
So we were involved in kind of
characterizing this duplication.
It turns out that the actual gene itself
wasn't in the human genome in 2012.
So we had to actually go
and clone and sequence it.
In 2012 it turns out
there was only one copy
in the human reference
and there are actually
four of which one is a clear pseudo gene.
Ancestor produced a
daughter called SRGAP2A
about 3.2 million years ago
with a secondary duplication
leading to SRGAP2C which is
this duplicate truncated form
that antagonizes the function
that's thought to be important in terms of
altering spine development
as well as excitatory
and inhibitory synapses.
The other story you heard
was from Wieland Huttner.
We discovered this or at
least the duplicated sequence
back in the early 2000s and
actually characterized it
and reconstructed the
evolutionary history in 2014.
And this was a gene
that as you heard today
thought to be important
in terms of increasing
the number of basal radial glial divisions
or also known as auto
ventricular cell divisions
that may be important in terms
of increasing neuronal count.
The common theme about these
is that each of them are truncated
with respect to the parent copy
so they're not full length.
These genes or these duplications
are also associated with
genomic instability.
So in the case of 15q13
that's associate with
that schizophrenia form
and as well as epilepsy
that I showed you earlier.
And in these particular
cases it looks as if
the duplication itself may have been
the incomplete nature but
may have been important
for the neo functionalization of it
for the actual evolution of new function.
So I'm gonna end with a
story on this last one
which we just recently published
and we continue to characterize.
So this is this picture of chromosome 16
I showed you before.
And I'm gonna zoom in on
these duplication blocks
that evolved over the
last few million years
in the evolution of our genome.
And the reason that this particular
duplication pair is so important
is that recurrent rearrangements of it
actually results in the
second most common cause
of autism in the human species.
That is of a deletion
of chromosome 16 p11.2
and the 25 to 28 genes
that map between these.
So this is the second most
common cause of autism
genetically known in the human population.
Result of duplications
that evolved specifically
in the last few million
years in our species.
So I convinced a student
about four years ago
to go and characterize this
and do a comparative evolutionary study
which almost no one ever seems
to do at the genetic level
because they think the genomes are done.
And so, in a week moment he agreed,
so the student was named Xander Nuttle.
And this was just showing
you kind of our sequencing.
So the way he did it was
kind of old-fashioned.
He took large insert
clones and sequenced them
and reassembled because we
didn't trust the genomes
that were assembled.
And the way I'm gonna
show you these pictures,
I'm just going to show you,
this is a portion of
chromosome 16 on the orangutan
where the little ticks represent genes.
So there's 48 genes that
are represented here.
The color represents
the duplicated sequence,
at least in my life I
always put that in color.
And then the actual
arrows here indicate the
kind of the what we call synteny.
So it's the order of these segments
with respect to other mammalian species.
So other than the duplications,
this order and these genes is
completely syntenic with mouse
which diverged about 80
to 90 million years ago,
so we believe this is the ancestral state.
So then he repeated the experiment
by looking at gorillas, chimps and humans.
So I'm gonna show you
two chimps and two humans
or one human right now for the exact same
region of the genome.
This is the exact same area of the genome.
This, it's 1.4 megabases
or a million base pairs in orangutan.
And these are the two chimp versions
of this particular portion
of chromosome 16 right here.
And there's the human for comparison.
Now the colors remember
represent the duplications
and the arrows represent the segments.
And so, the first thing
you should get from this
when you look at it you say,
god, that doesn't look
even close to the same,
and you'd be right.
Because this area of the genome
has essentially doubled in size
as a result of duplications
in the chimp and the human lineage.
Those are all the color bars.
The interesting thing is,
is that the patterns of duplications
are almost completely different
between chimp and human.
So remember the different colors represent
different evolutionary origins.
And you can see that there are some things
that are similar, these little red ticks
are those Core Duplicons but by and large,
the structure is radically different.
More interestingly, if
you actually look at
the actual segments of the DNA itself
you can see that they're
complete ordered differently
between a chimp and a human.
These segments, these
six segments of 48 genes
have been shuffled around
in completely different combinations.
In fact my student
estimated parsimoniously
that you would need 13
large-scale structural changes
to actually convert a human
to a chimp structure over this.
So the idea that we're 99%
in this region of the genome
actually has no meaning.
We are so radically different
but over a very focaled
region of our genome.
Coming back to disease,
this is the area that
causes autism in our kids
and it's because we
have these duplications
in a direct orientation of
the same type on either side.
If you look at the chimp region five,
both haplotypes they don't have this.
They don't have the
duplication architecture
that would predispose to disease.
In other words they are not predisposed
to developing this form of autism
because they don't actually
have the architecture
to predispose the instability.
So what are humans look
like if you compare them?
So thankfully we look much
more similar to one another,
so this is three different
human chromosomes
that are being compared.
But we do differ
and we differ over only one portion
and this is indicated here
by these orange and green arrows.
There's a set of, there's a
region about a hundred kilobases
that is expanding and
contracting like accordions
on this region which
predisposes to autism.
But on either side we're
expanding and contracting
this hundred kilobase cassette.
And if you look really carefully
you'll see that there are four genes
right over the area of change.
and these are genes that are important
both in drug detoxification we have found
but also a gene's important
in terms of iron metabolism,
this gene called BOLA2.
This is a gene that's actually been shown
biochemically both in vitro and in vivo
to be important in terms
of recruiting more iron
into a cell and and
helping it to essentially
become stable in terms of the
proteins that it produces.
So how do humans vary if you
look at thousands of them?
This is 2,500 humans
that we're comparing now
for copy number of this
hundred kilobase segment
which contains this BOLA2 gene
and here's the interesting part.
You look at humans from all
the different continents
and they're quite variable
in terms of their copy.
But all of them or I
should say none of them
go back to the ancestral
state is what you see
in chimps, gorillas and orangutans.
So every human has at least three.
Most of us have five or
six of this duplication.
A few at three but none go back to two
is what you see in these species.
And here's where it gets really cool.
If you compare to Neanderthal and Denisova
which you've heard a little bit about,
they separated from us very recently,
only about 400,000 to 500,000 years ago,
they look like chimps and gorillas
in terms of their copy number.
If we look at archaic hominins
or I should say archaic
humans not hominins,
archaic humans so this would be humans
that lived 30,000 to 40,000 years ago,
they look like us.
This is 400,000 years ago,
this is 50,000 years ago.
So what's really remarkable is that
when we estimate the
time and we can do this
with phylogenetic approaches,
we estimate the birth of
this duplication to being
about 282,000 years ago.
This is where most
paleontologists estimate the root
of the species Homo sapiens.
Of course, the plus or
minus is 75,000 here.
(audience laughs)
One thing we can show from
basically doing a work,
using methods involving evolutionary
or phylogenetic methods is that the rate
at which this expanded is
too rapid to be explained
based on strictly neutral evolution.
So this is not evolving neutrally.
It's actually the fact
that we haven't gone back
to the actual ancestral
state is very unusual
specifically for a duplication
where copy number variation
is always occurring.
And copy number of this piece of DNA
actually correlates expressions.
So those of you who have more copies
actually have more of
this bullet two expressed.
We looked at this in terms
of expression differences
between chimp and human with Rusty.
So he had actually
published this early work
that he mentioned already
looking at induced pluripotent stem cells
in chimps, bonobos and humans.
And even though it didn't
make his top 10 list,
it should have
because this gene was actually expressed
7.5 fold higher on average in the chimp
or I should say the human
compared to the chimp.
And the reason when we went
back and looked at this
is because there was variance
in actually the copy
number estimates in human
because he looked at more than one human.
So we did these experiments with his group
and we could show that in
fact there is a big difference
between humans and chimps and bonobos.
But the biggest difference
happens early in development,
what we consider induced
pluripotent stem cells.
There's still some difference
between these NPCs,
neuronal progenitor cells
but that's the biggest
difference that we see.
The one last point I'll
make is that in fact
when we actually look at
the actual gene itself
there is just a simple duplicate gene
which is entirely represented.
But because these
duplications are often mosaic
we actually have identified a gene
which looks like a complete fusion
of part of BOLA2 with another
serine threonine kinase
which now makes a duplication
that has a fusion duplication
that has an open reading frame.
This is in fact to my knowledge
the only Homo sapien-specific gene
that distinguishes chimp
or I should say humans
from Neanderthals and Denisova
because Denisova and Neanderthals
do not have this duplication
therefore do not have the fusion.
Coming back to the disease.
Going back to the kids
that actually have autism
and mapping the breakpoints of those kids,
where did those break
point specifically occur?
96% of the children that we've looked at
that have this break point
associate with autism,
their break point maps to
the Homo sapien-specific
segment that evolved on the order of about
280,000 years ago.
And then this is just to
show you that if we look at
those kids that have low copy number
because those kids do
have lower copy than most,
we in fact find out that
in fact half of them
and the numbers are still small,
they have problems with anemia
and require iron supplementation
compared to the rest of the kids
with this particular deletion
who still have high copies
of BOLA2 which do not have anemia,
or they very have low incidence of anemia.
So we think it's actually
relevant also to disease
and kids that are anemic with autism.
So in summary, I hope I've convinced you
how cool our genome and how
absolutely chaotic it is
with respect to duplications.
That we've had this burst of duplications
that has occurred on the order of
eight to 15 million years ago
before we separated a species
but as we were separating the species.
This wired us for disease
so we actually have a lot of additional
recurrent structural changes in our genome
as a result of this
duplication architecture.
But this has come with benefits
and we think that and we hypothesize
the Core Duplicon hypothesis is that the
negative result of having
this interspersed architecture
is offset by the emergence of new genes
we consider SRGAP2C and ARHGAP11B
to be some of our best
examples of these types
but we think there'll be others.
And we also think BOLA2 is
particularly interesting
because it's a Homo
sapien-specific expansion
which we think will be
relevant for iron homeostasis
or improving our ability to recruit iron.
And at the same time is predisposing us
to the most common or
second most common cause
of autism in the human species.
So when I think about the
evolution of our genome
and this is the way I think about it,
I think of actually a balancing act
between both disease and evolution.
These are the folks that did all the work
and I will show you Seattle in the sun
because this is just to show you
that the sun does shine in Seattle.
Thank you
(audience applauding)
(uptempo music)